[Music]
the other day i was watching my favorite
ghibli movie ponyo and i got
this scene and i was like god i will
share with them
and then i started thinking maybe i can
recreate this so i can finally make my
dreams of living in a ghibli movie come
true
so first i tried to recreate the photo
with the green screen effect
but it just wasn't doing it for me so i
went back to scrolling on instagram
hopeless sad and ready to give up
but then i scrolled past
my dear friend escaping you i had a
bright idea
so before i went to bed that night i
texted natalia to see if she could help
oh sakura messaged me she said i'm
trying to do a studio ghibli shoot
please help this is my friend natalia so
i knew she was gonna be perfect for this
because
she's really good at making something
out of literally nothing and she does
all sorts of crazy edits of things like
this
i thought we'd have to figure out a
shoot irl since you know since
one or two people shoot's not done like
that but
turns out since she was in california
and i was on the east coast we were
gonna have to rely on some italian magic
okay i'm going to the store now i don't
see
anything that i need i couldn't find
brown pants i couldn't find
anything and meanwhile not exactly the
right color but i'll change it in
photoshop
i did not get that memory i ended up
finding stuff that would be like
good enough and uh we went off to the
shoot so to start things off natalia
went to the side of a building with a
nice staircase because she could hold on
to the railing to make it look like she
was flying
but the lighting so she decided to go to
a second spot
nice solid colors in the foreground
background you know so it would be
easier to edit but the lighting isn't so
great
so we're gonna try again you know what
they say third time's the charm so
obviously this is gonna work just
kidding even though this one had the
most ghibli
feel the magic was lacking the sun was
setting things were starting to look a
little dreary
then fourth time's the charm jackpot
the perfect amount of greenery and
amazing lighting now you might be
wondering
how how how does it look i got the
wheelchair
i'll show you that in a second back to
me
so natalia kind of struggled finding the
right lighting i was kind of dealing
with much more
primal things like uh wild deer
and dogs eating every leaf unlike
natalia i am not a self-portrait artist
so i had my lovely boyfriend carlos set
up the camera for me
instead but i'll have you know i braved
through that 37 degree weather in
short that was my idea that we're gonna
since the first location didn't work out
because there was a little too much
going on we moved over to a park instead
got the shot
sent the goodbyes back over to natalia
and now it was time
to edit in other words natalia was
working her
magic yes i can't wait to show sakura
oh my god the very first time i set my
eyes on this picture
i teared up i swear to god if you want a
better look at the picture check out my
instagram at cucumbrain or escaping
youth anyway thanks for joining me on
this ghibli journey
see you next time bye